it was the seat of learning that became
a target in last week's whites
this school in the predominantly Muslim
area of Mustafa bod in northeast Delhi
was set on fire by a mob repairs are
hurriedly being done to allow students
to sit their final exams in five days
time the attacks happened after Hindu
nationalists incited violence following
peaceful protest against India's
citizenship law some damage will be
harder to fix in the nearby al hin
Clinic victims of the violence wait to
have their wounds treated both these men
say they were shot while attending a
Muslim gathering we didn't get any
support from anyone the law failed us
they didn't help us in any way possible
no we don't need justice from them we
only need justice from our God during
the three days of violence this doctor
says he treated more than 600 people in
this clinic and the injuries were
gruesome some people had bullet injuries
while some had stab injuries were
Whitely parts like their hurt and lungs
were injured more than a week on and
accusations are mounting of how police
not only assisted Hindu nationalists but
also prevented ambulances from answering
emergency calls to help wounded Muslims
we know that more than 40 people were
killed in the violence and officially
350 people were injured what we don't
know is how many were Muslim and how
many were Hindu and so far the
authorities have not released results of
post-mortem examinations to show how
they died the family of 23 year old
faizon want answers he was one of a
number of young Muslim men who was
seemingly beaten by police in this video
posted on social media he died in
hospital of his injuries two days later
we suspect that it could be the police
army or paramilitary but we cannot be
sure about who it was the police have
arrested more than 800 people they don't
include senior members of the ruling BJP
party the human rights activists accused
of inciting the violence one of the
arrested a Muslim has been charged with
murder he's
says he was framed and was only
defending his family it is certainly a
state-sponsored a pogrom
it is certainly state-sponsored targeted
violence against Muslims there are
concerns that right-wing Hindu
nationalists will use the recent
violence as an excuse to spread
anti-muslim feeling around the country
more than 150,000 Muslims live in the
overcrowded alleyways of Northeast Delhi
there is fear and apprehension that what
happened 10 days ago is only a precursor
to what lies ahead Tony Bert Lee al
Jazeera must have a bad Delhi